equipped with a powerful jaw and
Incredibly sharp teeth the T-Rex
dominated the Cretaceous
Kingdom it was one of the most dominant
Predators history has ever seen this
colossal Beast wasn't just Scavenging
leftovers it was an active Hunter
stalking its prey with Keen eyesight and
a heightened sense of smell among its
favorite meals were the sizable
herbivores like the
Edmontosaurus but the T-Rex didn't stop
there it would take on formidable
opponents like the Triceratops and even
other smaller therapods if the
opportunity arose with its powerful jaws
filled with 12in teeth and its strong
hind limbs that allowed it to run at
speeds of up to 40 km per hour the T-Rex
was a master of the hunt